droht uns womöglich bald ein neuer krieg
krieg in europa das klingt unvorstellbar
aber wladimir putin hat 100 tausend
russische soldaten an die ukrainische
grenze verlegen lassen ganz nah an der
europäischen ausgrenzen damit auch ja
der russische präsident er spielt also
mit den muskeln hier sehen wir
satellitenbilder der panzer und
bataillone wie gefährlich ist dass putin
droht deutschland droht ganz europa und
vor allem droht er der ukraine erste
große herausforderung damit auch für die
neue ja noch unerfahrene außenministerin
annalena baerbock von den grünen wie
soll deutschland jetzt reagieren wer
bock hat auf solche fragen bisher ist
sie ausgewichen verweist aber auf ihr
telefonat mit dem ukrainischen
außenminister sie lynskey dem habe sie
die vollste deutsche solidarität
versichert ihre deutlichste aussage in
diesem zusammenhang ist diese hier wird
schon einmal jede form von eingriff in
die souveränität der ukraine würde
massive folgen für das russische regime
haben mit wirtschaftlicher und
diplomatischer
natur das interessanteste an dieser
äußerung ist das nicht von einer
russischen regierung sondern von einem
regime spricht und besorgte ist auch
kiews bürgermeister und excel box
weltmeister vitali klitschko würde er
kämpfen wenn es ernst wird bild vize
paul ronzheimer hatte gestern die
gelegenheit mit ihm über die aktuelle
situation zu sprechen
die situation in der ukraine
insbesondere an der grenze zu russland
spitzt sich zu über 100.000 truppen sind
auf der seite in russland und drohen in
richtung die ukraine zu gehen und putin
droht ganz bewusst und sie zugeschaltet
ist der bürgermeister von kiew und ex
boxweltmeister vitali klitschko schönen
guten tag vitali
montag heraus kamen
alle
freue mich sehr danke für ihre werbung
wenn wir uns die situation anschauen wie
ernst ist es glauben sie dass putin den
truppen befehl geben wird dass er
weitere truppen richtung keine schickt
dass er die ukraine einnehmen will
letzter zeit alle sprecher und wie
möglich verschiedene möglich ist so nah
der die entwicklung von dieser situation
ich hoffe dass es seinem
spielen
eine bedrohung ich hoffe dass es wird
niemals zum krieg kommen
dass es das wird eine alptraum für
beides lernen und noch eine konflikte
oder in der ukraine
wir mussten nicht vergessen noch eine
der großen europäischen land und von
stabile
wirtschaftliche und politische situation
abhängt die diskussion in europäische
gemeinde in europäischen und deswegen
wir hoffen auf unterstützung politischer
untersuchung von unsere europäischen
partner
in den bereich
russlands zu stoppen und muss auf keinen
fall zum eine aktive
phase zu kommen dass die frage was
machen solche truppe ersten mal in die
geschichte durch reine soviel
militäreinheiten stehen dann grenze
durch rheine wo ist und so spielen
wie bereiten sie sich persönlich vor sie
waren auch militär in der vergangenheit
haben den dienst geleistet und sie haben
angekündigt dass wenn es so weit kommen
würde sie einen eid geschworen haben und
auch bereit sind ihr land zu verteidigen
wir haben wie bereiten sich die stelle
ist er zuständig für viele
verschiedene szenario ich hoffe zum
schlimmsten kommt nicht und das ist eine
bedrohung
für durch eine
aber wenn dann denke ich mal die jede
ukraine muss sein land und unsere
sortiert und zentrale integrität zu
verteidigen das ist sehr wichtig für uns
wie greifen nicht an und wir sind auf
unsere wand und wir wollen unser land
beteiligen seite stellen die sind die
grund
grund wieso ist so eine luca noch reine
kommt dass unsere wunsch ein teil von
europäischen familie zu sein ein teil
von europäische union zu sein um das
passt nicht in die pläne wieder große
russische reich wieder aufzubauen das
ist grund von meiner sicht wie so etwas
passiert
klitschko es gibt gleichzeitig die frage
und die debatte darüber was deutschland
machen kann jetzt wurden defensivwaffen
bislang verweigert was erwarten sie von
deutschland was sollte deutschland tun
um die ukraine zu unterstützen
ich möchte zu kommen in die geschichte
in alles in 90 jahren noch als seine
atomwaffen gegeben freiwillig die unsere
internationale partner hat garantiert
für die kleine
integrität um unabhängigkeit
deswegen wurden im raum bonn muss
verwickeln muss realisiert und deswegen
wir erwarten von unterstützung von alle
europäischen länder und von allende war
bei der techno-parade doch hat
unterschrieben wie bereitet sich ihre
heimatstadt wo sie bürgermeister sind
auf einen möglichen krieg vor
wir bereiten für alle thema der
beteiligung sehr viel ständig die jeder
das zum diesem sommer kommt die jeder
war in
köln seine
militärische ausbildung hat muss sein
staat unser land beteiligen die
beteiligung unserer heimat das ist
eine
eher denkt man für eine echte bogen für
echte patrioten das zu machen herzlichen
dank vitali klitschko für das gespräch
und alles gute nach kiew
wir hoffen dass es wir treten wir wollen
keinen krieg und wir geben alle
von unserer seite dass es frieden muss
bleiben in unserem land und wir hoffen
auf unterstützung
von europäische länder um besonders vom
durchsuchung zu bekommen